Welcome to JAM !
Avec: Vincent Tirel,
Julien Josselin
Kyan Kojandhi,
Adrien Ménielle
et Jérôme Niel !
Ils ont eu une journée pour tourner un sketch improvisé.
Handicaps: un des personnages a un frère jumeau.
Objet à placer : un yoyo.
Phrase à placer :
"Parce que tu savais pas qu’ils savaient
que tu savais et moi non plus. "
Oui c’est ça.
(cris)
C’est pas commode !
Il t’a vraiment dit ça ?
Ouais.
Enfin je crois.
Enfin mon psy dirait que
c’est ce que j’aurais voulu qu’il dise.
Je vois un psy, tu vois un psy ?
Euh …
Tous les vendredis. 17h.
J’ai footing, psy, piscine,
et après je tue des gens. Ca me détend.
Et toi alors, comment ça va ?
Ben, moi je galère un peu, je …
Pourtant c’est une belle trace de sang ça, c’est très joli.
Ah non, ça c’est les pâtes bolo que j’ai mangé …
Quoi ?
C’est le pote prolo que j’ai tué, je …
Ah oui d’accord.
Bon, on revient à mon histoire.
On va crever bordel !
J’ai plus de réseau !
Les amis,
si vous comptez sortir d’ici vivant,
je vous conseille de m’é…
(cris)
Lui je l’ai tué direct.
Ben oui, il met les gens en confiance,
après les gens s’en sortent et c’est pas le but, tu vois.
Et tu lui as dit quoi comme réplique stylée ?
Je sais pas, un truc du genre :
« Ta vie ne tenais …
qu’à un fil. »
Wow!
Moi j’ai du mal avec les phrases d’accroche.
Ah bon ? Tu dis quoi ?
Ben …
Attention les yeux !
Coucou !
Qui c’est que v’là !
Paf ! Ca sort du placard,
et pourtant je suis pas homosexuel !
Bip bip !
Et alors, ça va ?
(tousse)
Bonjour, je viens pour le meurtre.
Ouais, c’est bien, c’est bien.
Mais tu sais, l’essentiel,
c’est la mise en scène.
Oh ! Non mais tu te téléportes ou quoi, c’est pas possible ça.
Mais non. Y’a un truc.
Y’a toujours un truc. J’ai un frère jumeau, Réginald.
Réginald!
Et ouais mon pote. C’est comme ça que je les prends mes victimes.
Par surprise.
Je l’ai pas vue venir celle-là.
Et non, tu l’as pas vue venir.
Parce que tu savais pas
qu’ils savaient
que tu savais
et moi non plus.
Quoi ?
Oui, je travaille. Les répliques.
Oui, bien joué.
JAM c’est un jeu, on a une journée pour tourner un sketch.
Kyan et Jérôme savent toujours pas où ils vont.
Moi je sais un peu parce que Julfou a bourdé tout à l’heure.
On est sur le tournage du premier JAM.
Objet à placer : un yoyo.
Tu sais on l’a pas placé pendant le sketch, à la fin :
On se rend compte qu’on est vraiment en retard en fait.
Jérôme part dans 50 minutes, on a rien tourner.
Oh ! Quel suspense !
J’ai absolument envie de voir Making JAM,
je suis content !
Et tu peux proposer le prochain objet à placer dans les commentaires.
On choisira parmi les plus populaires.
Le yoyo, c’est déjà pris.